Without a doubt, Oberyn Martell is the best
one-off character in Game of Thrones.
And Bobby B exists so there’s tough competition
for that title.
Oberyn I think is the most universally likable
character in the entire show.
This is because of his great personality with
unbreakable charisma, along with a deep well
of other lovable personality traits.
Then he’s brought to life perfectly by Pedro
Pascal and this was really his breakthrough
performance as an actor.
Before this, he had minor roles in television,
so he proved himself here and it opened a
gateway into getting better roles.
It just seems like he plays Oberyn effortlessly
and with so much confidence to the point that
you couldn’t see anyone else as that character.
The first area I want to tackle for understanding
why Oberyn is such a perfect character is
the writing.
And then we can go into more detail about
Pedro’s performance and then the external
factors about the character that make him
even better.
Upon rewatching all of Oberyn’s scenes,
I realized each one of them introduces and
showcases a new personality trait.
It makes his scenes feel very efficient because
we keep learning new aspects tied to the character.
Going through his scenes, we have his opening
where it’s shown he’s a courageous, fearless,
badass.
His scene with Tyrion shows him to be vengeful.
He’s able to suavely play politics at Joffrey’s
wedding, He’s a compassionate lover who
wants to experience all of the desires in
the world, he has strong composure and doesn’t
act on impulse in the face of Tywin, he’s
a kind intellectual who writes poems and treats
Myrcella with care, the small council meeting
shows him to have an air of disobedience,
and with all of this, he’s even able to
be sincere with Tyrion in the dungeons.
Almost all of his scenes are productive on
a character development level.
And even though there’s a proficiency in
character development, the writers don’t
compromise any plot development and are able
to expertly do both.
Like an example being his first scene in which
it gives you the entire essence of Oberyn
while also explaining his entire motivation
and backstory.
So right away you understand the character.
I feel like this isn’t something to take
for granted because there are so many other
shows in which characters have way more screen
time than Oberyn, but yet, they are significantly
more dull.
Oberyn’s scenes are meticulously planned
and aspects of his character are always being
revealed to the viewer.
It makes all of his scenes much more entertaining
and thus makes him even more alluring.
Through all of his screen time, you are also
searching for any character flaws and negative
traits and that finally shows up in his last
scene.
During his fight with the Mountain, he gets
overconfident and thus becomes careless in
the pursuit of the truth.
So even though he’s a very colorful character
with many likable traits, he’s still a flawed
individual and that makes him human.
By his final scene, it comes full circle and
this final trait finishes his character and
his overall arc.
Just a very efficient set-up and pay-off in
the course of only eight episodes.
That’s an achievement in of itself from
how great of a character George was able to
write in that short amount of time.
Another clever thing I picked up on on rewatch
was how much the writers emphasized the mystery
of Oberyn.
All of his opening scenes generally paint
him as more of a villain because he openly
says that he hates the Lannisters.
At the ending of each of these scenes, they
generally end with an open threat.
Like the way, his first interaction ends with
Tyrion.
This is also the first episode of the season,
so at this point in the story, you assume
that Oberyn will be a possible catalyst to
blow up conflict in Kingslanding.
Throughout the show, we are taught not to
trust anyone.
So this new character showing up according
to things we learned earlier and general story
tropes, tells us that Oberyn is not to be
trusted.
Especially since he openly made his objective
well known.
So the twist in which he actually turns out
to be a good guy is that much more surprising
because he shattered our expectations of this
new mysterious character.
That and this whole scene was brilliantly
written.
Easily one of my favorite monologue scenes
that is imbued with so much emotion.
Up until this point, we’ve never seen Oberyn
in this more sensitive light, so seeing him
have a moving scene with Tyrion was special.
Along with it even adding in more backstory
about how Cersei and other people hyped up
Tyrion as being a hideous monster as a baby
when in reality he wasn’t.
It makes for a great point for Oberyn to sympathize
with Tyrion and him choosing to be his champion
was one of the most uplifting moments in Game
of Thrones.
Tyrion at this point in the story has utterly
lost and even his own brother and best friend
won’t fight for him, so Oberyn coming in
out of left field to help him was a great
twist.
Which if you’ve been paying attention, this
perfectly makes sense within the story because
of Oberyn’s vendetta against the Mountain.
But yet, it doesn’t come across as an obvious
point in the story because the Mountain is
so menacing and terrifying to the point of
no one wanting to fight him.
So overall, this is really the turning point
for Oberyn’s character that really makes
the audience rally for him.
This is his purpose within the show and now
he’s extremely important.
The amount of stakes tied to his character
has drastically surged and the upcoming mountain
fight makes you hyped as hell.
From here we can look at the Mountain vs.
the Viper scene and obviously, it has some
fun action, but what really floored me was
the writing.
The twist at the end where Oberyn gets overconfident
and gets blindsided by his vengeance for Tywin,
and makes a misstep that costs him his life
is probably the most shocking twist right
behind the Red Wedding.
The reason why this twist rocks you so hard
is because it was very unpredictable and because
of Tyrion’s fate.
For the last 3 seasons, Tyrion has been the
primary protagonist in Kingslanding.
So going into this trial by combat, you assume
that there is a fair chance that Tyrion will
survive given his importance, along with Oberyn
being this new and dominant character.
So surely they won’t kill him right?
Right!??
Then to even combat the suspicion that Oberyn
will lose, they actually make it to where
he wins, and then in a freak accident, he
dies.
This is literally the best outcome from a
writing perspective and I can’t imagine
a better way to have written this scene.
It’s a roller coaster in which you experience
the highs of winning and the lows of losing.
It’s a massive rug pull just when you think
all the danger is gone.
It feels like George RR.
Martin is playing mind games with you because
you know the most logical twist will be for
Oberyn to win, but then that in turn now seems
like a predictable outcome.
George somehow accounts for this and blows
us away with what ends up happening.
Along with him obliterating the status quo
of the show because as an audience, we assume
that Tyrion will return to what he’s been
doing in Kingslanding.
So by completely sending Tyrion in an unknown
direction, it leaves viewers not being able
to predict where the story goes, and thus,
this was the least expected outcome.
Another crazy thing is that Oberyn not killing
the Mountain is not contrived.
Oberyn is trying to desperately question the
Mountain for information and this makes sense
because this objective has been established
in multiple scenes.
In order to subvert expectations in a narrative
it needs to make sense within the story because
here it works expertly.
Meanwhile, in the later seasons, it utterly
shatters the logic in order to pull off hollow
shocking moments.
Like Rhaegal’s death scene being the biggest
offender where Dany forgets about the iron
fleet despite being reminded of it and getting
sniped out of the sky.
This may quote on quote shock the viewer,
but it’s met with confusion and anger because
it compromises any realistic notion within
the story.
In essence, it’s bullshit.
And David and Dan keep doing this throughout
seasons 7 and 8.
So Oberyn’s final scene is the literal opposite
of this because it’s logical and is driven
by two amazing characters.
I know I took some of the emphasis off of
Oberyn and talked about this overall scene,
but it clearly wouldn’t be possible without
Oberyn.
The reason why his death hits so hard is because
he was such a lovable character who was taken
away so soon.
His presence was short and sweet, and because
of this, he’s a straight-up perfect character
because his time in the story has absolutely
no downtime or flaws.
Like it’s a lot harder to call other characters
perfect considering their trajectory for the
later seasons, unless if you just ignore their
later seasons altogether.
Another thing about Oberyn’s scenes is that
he contrasts really well to certain characters,
and the writers take advantage of that.
Like one of my favorite pairings was Oberyn
talking to Varys in the throne room.
Oberyn is a man who loves pursuing desires
and is constantly indulging himself at every
opportunity he can get.
So this being contrasted to someone who has
no sexual desires genuinely confounds Oberyn.
And Varys even says that he’s had no desires
even before being a eunuch.
This is the antithesis as to how Oberyn operates
and their interaction because of this was
very engaging.
The part in the script where Oberyn asks Varys
what his true desire is given his lack of
sexual ambition, and all he does is look over
at the Iron Throne and is a genius point in
the script.
This kind of contrast can also be seen in
his small council scene.
What is a man who is so disobedient doing
in a setting in which you have to serve the
hand.
All the characters here want to kiss Tywin’s
ass, while Oberyn definitely does not.
The rivalry between Oberyn and Mace Tyrell
is really funny and it shows the stark differences
between what these characters value so much.
One is a boot licker who will do anything
for Tywin, while the other refuses to stand
when he enters the room and is lounging in
his seat.
These kind of scenarios the writers put Oberyn
into are so intriguing because he sticks out
much more from these major differences.
It amplifies his characteristics and ideologies
because they aren’t normal in this setting.
So they essentially stand out like a sore
thumb.
On the ideology front, his quick snappy exchange
with Cersei about how Dorne doesn’t despise
bastards creates a good conflicting point
for these characters to bud heads on.
So by putting Oberyn into settings that fundamentally
contrast his character, it puts a spotlight
onto what makes him so original.
From a writing point of view, I think Oberyn
is the best example you can pull on, as to
how to expertly set up and literally execute
a new character.
From every scene being very productive in
what they teach us about Oberyn and his personality,
playing into the mysterious angle of his character
to make him more intriguing, contrasting him
to certain characters and settings to amplify
his characteristics, and every twist he’s
involved in perfectly utilizes him as a character.
Truly a flawless character who gets even better
from an acting standpoint from what Pedro
Pascal brings to the table.
You know what?
Let’s do a little test.
Do you think Pedro Pascal won any awards for
playing Oberyn Martell or at the very least
was nominated?
The answer is surprisingly no and not even
any nominations.
But between most of the characters in this
season, I think Pedro Pascal’s screen presence
was so infectious.
He nailed every characteristic of Oberyn perfectly
and there was a lot to nail.
As I said before, every scene essentially
showcases a new characteristic.
So from an acting standpoint, it’s really
impressive to me that Pedro Pascal was able
to gracefully portray each of these characteristics
so well.
This also requires a ton of range from Pedro
because he has to show heaps of charisma,
confidence, stoicness, and on the opposite
side of the spectrum he has to be vulnerable.
If it wasn’t for his monologue with Tyrion,
he would have just been a fun character, but
this scene really cements him as an emotional
powerhouse.
This kind of reminds me of Robert Baratheon.
In most of his scenes, he’s either being
a strict ruler or a memeing menace, but the
scene where he gets real with Cersei and talks
about their marriage in detail really unveils
a hidden side to his character.
This is what Oberyn’s scene with Tyrion
is to me, and is even better because it has
a strong progression throughout the entire
scene.
Pedro is able to build to the point of sincere
sadness by first starting out in a more playful
mood.
He starts out cracking some jokes and we first
think he’s chastising Tyrion when he talks
about how people called him a devilish baby.
Then slowly through this captivating monologue,
he sympathizes and feels bad for Tyrion to
the point of where he’s shedding a tear.
It’s an extremely cathartic moment and this
low-key scene again shows Oberyn’s more
heartwarming side.
So overall for his range, it’s showcased
in spades and he’s more than a badass warrior.
For another aspect about his acting that I
feel like is hard to achieve, is the amount
of charisma he portrays.
This is an aspect that a lot of leading actors
can lack and it becomes very noticeable if
the actor doesn’t feel confident in the
character.
If they lack this confidence then their performance
will in turn become dull.
But what makes an actor great, is if they
make you believe they truly are that character
and don’t come across as just reading lines.
This requires a lot more involvement from
the actor and establishing more detailed aspects
like the voice of the character, inflection,
cadence, and the way they physically hold
themselves.
You can make an easy distinction between great
and bad actors if each one of these areas
aren’t different for their characters.
Like Daniel Day Lewis essentially re-writes
his entire genetic make-up when entering a
new character, and then on the other hand,
the Rock or Kevin Hart essentially play themselves
in every role.
Pedro Pascal as Oberyn feels very distinct
in each one of these areas.
His voice has a unique accent given that he’s
from Dorne, his inflection is very particular,
and regularly puts emphasis on certain words
for bigger dramatic impact and he has the
cadence of a smooth river, and then physically
he simultaneously feels like an untouchable
god while also being very particular and smart
with how he moves.
Like once you really start to think about
the work Pedro Pascal is putting in here,
it’s like uncovering a deeper iceberg.
From all of this meticulous care being put
into the character he comes across as very
comfortable and he thoroughly understands
him.
So much to the point that he occasionally
adds in subtle improvisations that made his
character more real and natural.
It’s kind of hard to identify improvisations
without access to the script, but I’ll show
a couple examples.
The first one is my favorite where Oberyn
gracefully swipes his hand through the wick
of a candle, which boosted his badass meter
by a huge degree.
Then this one moment during Tywin’s dialogue
scene shows how lively Oberyn is.
These spontaneous small actions breathe life
into the character.
A lot of actors are just concerned about hitting
their marks for blocking and delivering lines
to the point that they feel restricted in
a way.
Pedro Pascal breathes instinctiveness into
his performance and through these improvisations,
it communicates a visual language of the character
that he’s more natural.
And he’s more natural because he’s actively
engaging and feeling confident in his environment,
which in turn aids his performance.
Pedro also seems like he’s having a blast
playing the character in all of his scenes
and that comes through very apparently.
Going back to the opening of this segment,
it’s a shame that Pedro Pascal as Oberyn
didn’t get any award recognition which feels
ironic because of how iconic the character
is.
This literally put him on the map and I think
he deserved much more credit back then.
To finish up the video, I quickly want to
go into one external factor that makes Oberyn
even better.
At this point in Game of Thrones, we’ve
essentially hit the peak and in my opinion,
season 4 is the best season.
Every character is completely fleshed out
and they are all amazing in their own way.
So introducing a new character like Oberyn
I feel like would be a daunting task because
you now have to make a character that is of
the same caliber of our pre-existing ones.
And the main external reason that makes him
inherently so interesting is the fact that
he’s from Dorne.
He offers a unique perspective in the already
vast world of Game of Thrones.
We’ve essentially seen representation and
the different ways of life in most of Westeros
and out of all of them, Dorne is really unique.
The people there are untamed and are resilient
to normal customs and seeing Oberyn in the
setting of a place that doesn’t communicate
his values, creates some good conflict and
juxtaposition.
We get to see some in-world racism like the
remarks the Lannister soldiers make towards
Oberyn.
This adds a lot of subtext about how people
view the dornish and this is very important
for how rich and huge the world is.
Now Dorne in the long run doesn’t end up
being that important given that the season
5 subplot was terrible and their impact in
the later seasons was non-existent, but Oberyn
in season 4 sets a good introductory point
for the Dornish culture.
So if the show happened to explore better
plotlines in Dorne, *clears throat* a better
book adaption of Dorne maybe, then this starting
point sets a good foundation to then explore
later on.
It’s just too bad that it was kind of wasted
and even though it was, it does not diminish
Oberyn’s brilliance in season 4.
Thank you for watching and I’m kind of curious
about how well this video performs.
Because I still have more Game of Thrones
videos I can make and want to do, but if the
interest around the show and viewership is
declining a lot, then I might prioritize making
other videos.
There is a series I want to start at some
point this year that I think will be very
fun and there is a lot of potential there.
But yeah, thank you again for watching, and
have a great day.